Welcome back.
In this lesson, you'll be developing
your very own portfolio page,
which you'll be able to
share with the world.
I know the layout looks different than
what you did before in the first lesson,
but don't worry.
I'll be helping you with an approach
that will make your life easier
by creating a CSS framework that you can
use in this project, in future projects.
You'll be able to make beautiful
pages like this without any problem.
Along the way, you'll be developing your
portfolio following responsive design
principles, which means that your
website is going to look great for
everyone, regardless of their device.
Are you ready to get started?